Hi, I am Danielle Oberdier,
the founder of DiKayoData.com,
data science media company,
and the Data Femme Podcast.
And I'm here to talk to
you about how content
makes our industry go round and
stay connected to one another.
So if you have more questions
because this is a lightning
talk, please reach out
on Twitter @dikayodata,
or at my site, DiKayoData.com.
I'm always happy to talk
and clarify more things
that I don't get to this time.
So what to make?
There are several
types of content
that you can make when you're
starting out making content.
One, obviously, is
an audio podcast
but that takes a ton of time
editing, finding guests,
finding sponsors, and
it's a lot of work,
whereas a blog is only
the amount of work
that you want to make it.
You can be amazing like Julia
Silge and do YouTube tutorials,
but that is not something
within my expertise.
I do blog.
I love it.
I love making tutorials
that people can just
look at really quickly without
turning off their TV shows
and just get right to the point.
I love writing about
general trends,
career trends in the industry.
What's interesting is that
long form content is totally
in average of 1,200 words,
is what is the most popular.
So if you want to just
write content every month,
every two months, and you
have something to say,
know that that long form
piece is going to be something
that people are interested in.
In terms of where
to share it, that's
where I just want to give a
shout out to email marketing.
Email marketing
is very important.
Nine out of 10 marketers
still use email
to promote their products,
and 81% of small businesses
use email as the primary
way of connecting
with their customers.
So I do have an email list.
I suggest that if you have
a product that you really
want to circulate
to your audience,
definitely set up an email.
There are so many ways to set
up an email list with your blog.
I recommend Squarespace,
and I am always
available to talk about
this, like I said.
Who it helps.
Obviously, having
content in our industry
really helps bring new
talent into the fold.
You can't just expect
to post on LinkedIn
and have all the right
people get to your message.
You do have to write content
that is targeted towards people
that might not feel comfortable
addressing certain issues
in the industry, talk to them,
bring them in, definitely think
about what kind of
content you're addressing,
think about current events, and
it obviously helps newcomers.
It also helps all
of us who might not
be newcomers to the field.
Why it matters.
Well, a lot of us don't
think about talking
more about content
after our work is
over with just the few
packages that we've
been working with all day
that our projects tend to use.
If we want to think outside the
box and relate to each other,
then the content that
we circulate really
fosters that discussion
outside of the workplace.
And I think it gives those of
us that are in higher positions
a way to connect
with other people
in other industries who are
doing really good things
that they didn't know about.
I know that Data Femme is
often a connector for people
who never would have met but
listen to the same podcast
and then end up having
a discussion maybe
on social media.
And here, we finally
get to how to succeed.
Consistency is really
important but you
can set the barometer for that.
You do not have to say that
consistency means every day.
It could mean once a month.
It could even mean once a
year for certain projects.
Really, what matters
is that you're
consistent about how you
promote your content.
You're consistent in having
discussions in person, at work,
on social media.
That really matters because that
is really the most important
of your content's life story,
is who it reaches and how.
So you can make the best
content in the world
but if it never
reaches anybody, you're
not going to really
succeed in the way
that the industry
could benefit from.
So definitely, no matter how
much you write or record,
make sure that you're
always having conversations
to help you grow, your content
grow, and the industry grow.
Thank you so much.